hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is myrna valerio
myrna is an ultra runner she's a trail
runner
she is a diversity educator she's also
a juilliard trained opera singer as well
as
an author of a great book called a
beautiful work in progress
this is myrna's second appearance on the
podcast her first was a couple years ago
and this conversation picks up where we
last left off
it's about what it means to be a runner
it's about
body positivity racial inclusion
social advocacy and many other
interesting
topics if you enjoy the work we do here
on the podcast please hit that subscribe
button
and without further ado this is me and
the murder
[Music]
well cool we're back to how many years
has it been since we did
three years almost three years yeah i
remember it vividly we were in your
hotel room you were in town for
some kind of education conference and we
were down in anaheim
it was fun dingy room at the embassy
suites i don't think but
i'm really happy to have you back here
today it's really nice to see you
although likewise i'm so happy to be
here yeah so a lot has changed in the
three years
since we last sat down culturally
socially of course
but but also personally for you i mean
you're
now a full-time professional athlete
basically
sure right if you want to put it that
way
uh i i usually call myself well i'm a
sponsored athlete but i do other things
as well
that makes you a professional athlete
okay fine you make your living as an
athlete
you get to travel around and do what you
love and talk about things that you love
which is pretty awesome
i do you're right you're absolutely
right so what was that like to
make that leap like you were you were an
educator at
like a private high school right right i
saw you i had
been in education for 18 years
when i decided that doing all of this
that i'm doing now
and teaching and working at a boarding
school
um was too much and also i was making
more money
doing the other stuff so i decided to
take a leap and it was a really giant
leap
out of education out of that security
net that i had just in terms of
everything in terms of
my salary in terms of health care and in
terms of somewhere to live
because i worked at boarding schools and
um
but i just decided to go for it and i
had the full support of my family
my kid stayed at the boarding school for
another year
while i figured out what and how i was
going to uh i was going to do this how i
was going to
plant myself somewhere and continue to
do all the media stuff and to do the
professional athlete thing and to
do everything else that i was doing and
it took a couple months it took
a long time to
believe that i could actually function
without being attached to a workplace so
this week
and but you know but again i had all
these
awesome opportunities i ended up in
vermont
right so when did you move to vermont
you were living in georgia i was living
in georgia and then after that after i
had to
move out of my house um because it was
school property
right i floated around a little bit i
lived in atlanta for the
summer in a friend's apartment and then
i headed my way back up to brooklyn and
slept on a couch for a couple of months
and when i decided that that was
that was enough of that i
you know on a whim decided to go up and
visit a friend
who lives in vermont and you know we
were gonna have a week of
adventure we were gonna ski and take a
snowboard lesson
do some indoor rock climbing um do some
snowshoeing
and so i went up there and
loved it for a week i only went for a
week
and decided that i needed to live there
in the dead of winter
and i discovered that
there were apartments at the inn where i
was staying and
i ended up staying at those apartments
and moved in the next month and i'm
not trying to move out of vermont again
like i'm not trying to move
anywhere that's it i love it i
absolutely love it it's the community
um that i think i need to be in i'm in
montpelier in the capital city
city unquote it's a very small same one
yes it's a hamlet the hamlet of
montpelier
and uh it's convenient my son
loves it he's 17 years old and
i've made him move to a lot of different
places and he
is having a great time here so
and tons of trails trails everywhere
like even though i'm in a stop
city i can
well i'm not running right now we can
talk about that later uh
i can you know walk or run uh to a trail
half mile away and you know just be
ensconced in the forest
right yeah that's cool so how come
you're not running right now
yeah i have a torn meniscus which is
really fun
it's your first first real injury well
i've noticed you've been out on the bike
a lot yeah uh we should talk about that
because it's my new sport now
but ultra cyclists i don't know about
ultra cycling but
um i definitely love uh being out there
on a bike but yeah i
uh had some achilles injuries
or an achilles injury still on my
left foot but you can run with that
um just takes a long time to recover
and then i started having issues in my
knees which i had never had to deal with
before
and and it just got worse and worse like
over the course of a month
you do that thing where you just pretend
it's going to go away and you keep
running
perhaps maybe
i don't know what you're talking about
richard um
and you know it would get better you
know for two days
and then it would get significantly
worse and then i finally
went on a big hike and uh and then that
night
my leg was really stiff and like the
whole leg was swollen and
that was um very very unusual and
so i finally went to the doctor mind you
during my transition from
being a full-time teacher to
this thing that i'm doing now i didn't
have health insurance
because yeah america and
so but i finally have health insurance
and so i decided to go and use it and
then it turned out to be um they thought
it was runner's knee at first
um a little bit of arthritis which that
runs in my family
and but then finally i went for an mri
and then they found out it was a torn
meniscus so i will have surgery
in a few weeks and hopefully that will
take care of a lot of the issues there
and
uh and i'll be back running and i really
miss it in the meantime you can ride a
bike
i can ride a bike i've been on a gravel
bike which
is my new second favorite thing i still
haven't done that
i got to get out on one of those oh man
it's phenomenal i mean
in vermont it's it's almost 50 right um
dirt road so
you run out of pavement really quickly
and you have to ride
dirt roads so and it's and it's so fun
it's
it's this thing this thing that i do now
and the family likes it in vermont
the family loves it mike i mean my son
loves it uh
my husband who lives part-time in new
york and also
in west africa he came up and visited
and
was like wow i can like
be on a mountain i can walk i can ride a
bike
i can eat really good food and relax
and it's clean here because he normally
lives in the bronx or in harlem
so it's a very different experience is
that just where his job is
well that's what we when he is in the
states he works as a truck driver and a
tow truck driver and some other things
and so that's where a lot of the work is
and so he stays down there and then
and then he goes home to run his
business which is in technology
and meanwhile you get to travel all
around and run races and talk to people
and talk about your book and stuff like
that and you've done a lot of races i
think
were you training for a hundred miler
when the injury happened or
no no i uh i know you were like i'm not
training for it 100 miler you're on like
good morning america
talking about dan harris about okay not
that long ago
well no i said i one day i would
like to maybe train for 100 one
100 miler all right um
but and then they gifted me uh good
morning america didn't but
uh tcs which is the title sponsor of the
tcs new york city marathon gifted me
four
of their races around the world
and uh and i told them in the interview
that
oh i'm gonna take 2020 to be a rest here
so that maybe i can
um start from zero and then start
training for
a 100 miler and then
they gifted me these four races for 2020
and i said okay well i'll just have to
put that off for a year but
then covet happened and yeah well
everybody's putting it off for a year
right so your injury kind of happened at
the correct it is the perfect
time and i'm actually really grateful
that it happened now
that uh that all the races are canceled
all the events are cancelled and now i
can just
take care of myself and rest how does it
feel to rest
a lot of runners get really
uncomfortable with that it's this is
like
yourself country extended taper period
that's what it is
um you know what it i actually haven't
had a whole lot of rest i you know to be
completely honest i've been
swamped with work since
i was actually in la in march for the la
marathon
and and then spent a couple of days out
west here and then
went back east and that's when
everything shut down
and i thought i would have some
time to just chill and sleep and i did
for about two weeks
but then i started getting a lot of
requests for
some motivational inspirational speaking
because people were
down in the dumps and so i did a lot of
that and i don't even
i don't market myself as a motivational
speaker or an inspirational speaker
i just tell my story i just talk about
what the things that are
i'm doing that bring me joy and uh
but i think people get a lot out of it
so um that's what i was doing
for a long time and then racism happened
or continues to happen
and then and then i was pulled and again
to even more work so i have i have been
working non-stop
basically yeah i want to get into how
you've been pulled back into this
education space but before we do that i
mean we went into your
story in great detail last time and
people should go back and listen to that
i love that episode um and the
conversation
but it might make sense for people who
haven't heard that to kind of recap your
story a little bit maybe you could do it
in the context of your your motivational
pitch
but i don't have a motivational pitch
share your story
share my story pull back in
um so in 2008 i had this health scare
where i thought i was having a heart
attack
and um it
turned out not to be a heart attack
thank goodness i
happened to be in a car on my way back
from a weekend gig
with my son in it and i started having
chest pains and
um eventually decided stupidly though
to continue home
and while i was having those chest pains
a colleague of mine took me to the
doctor took me to the emergency room
where it was determined that i wasn't
having
a heart attack but that i had had a
panic attack
which i thought was strange
uh and impossible for black people you
know because we're always so chill
and can't panic for and i even said that
to the doctor i said
black people don't have panic attacks
and he looked at me as i was i was crazy
yeah
and uh but then you know that set off a
a stream of
doctors appointments and cardiologist
appointments where the cardiologist that
i
that i eventually saw said that uh
basically that i was going to die
if i didn't change my lifestyle and
i heard him
very well i knew what he meant and so i
decided that i absolutely needed to
change
something in my life if you know if i
wasn't going to eventually have a
cardiac event
and so i got back on my treadmill and
this
incidentally this treadmill was one that
i had purchased a couple of months
before
but that i hadn't been using and it was
i use it as a closet like most people
i had shoes on it belts clothing coats
and uh and as i cleaned it off the next
day and got back on it
did my first mile in about three and a
half years
and that mile was very painful not just
physically but
mostly emotionally because i had let
myself get to a point where i couldn't
run a mile anymore and that felt really
awful and gross and
you like played field hockey yeah i
played high school field hockey i played
lacrosse both varsity
and um you know i was an athlete i'd
had been an athlete since high school
and you know i ran
on and off recreationally um throughout
my young adulthood
and i was i was always very very active
but when i
moved from new york to maryland that's
when things changed that's
um and i started gaining a bunch of
weight
and uh having lots of health issues
dental issues my kid was always sick and
i mean that's really the crux of
the whole stories my kid was always sick
which meant that i was always sick and i
was always missing work he
was always missing school um
and that is very very stressful um i was
living with
alone with him in maryland my husband
was in new york and
was that that inciting incident for the
panic attack that whole three-year
period
probably was uh because it was a very
stressful existence i
didn't enjoy my job a whole lot i
thought i was really good at it and i
think i was i was i was really good at
my job
but i was also balancing being you know
living the existence of a single parent
right while having this
job where where i wasn't appreciated
and um and so
i think that sort of culminated in a lot
of things happening with me physically
and then eventually i decided to leave
that job because it was just
it wasn't a healthy thing uh
for me to be doing with my family it
wasn't healthy for my family
either and so i moved back north to new
jersey
uh to an even more stressful job but at
least i was closer to family
and uh i and that's where i had
this health scare i was also
teaching i was teaching full-time i was
in grad school
i was obviously a mom and a wife
and i
was also teaching on the weekends too in
maryland and so
all that mixed up together
created this existence that wasn't very
healthy or helpful for me and that's why
i had that health scare and so i
when when that cardiologist told me that
i was gonna die if i didn't change my
lifestyle i
i really did make a decision to change
a lot of things i prioritized my day
i stopped bringing work home which is
really difficult to do
when you work in a boarding school i
um i would get up super early and and
hop on the treadmill for an hour
and then do pilates and and then do
awful
um biggest loser videos
really really awful but i did them
anyway uh
because i needed to change um
drastically and so i mean and i did i
would work out for five hours a day wow
yeah i was really committed to
changing my life um in a very drastic
way so
that's what i did right and uh little
little did you
know this entire new life that you live
now
right who knew what was the big
sort of was there a breakthrough moment
where you thought
where you really just embraced this idea
that i am a runner and this is like
the path that i'm gonna blaze for myself
i don't think there was one moment i
think i just slowly grew
into a running persona
and i never i never really had any
qualms about whether or not i was a
runner
like i i ran
therefore i was a runner but as far as
like
the really deep running persona
um and identifying deeply as a runner
i think that just came about organically
um and then it was it's always a
surprise to me that people who run
don't think they're runners because if
you run
you use your body for running it's
something you do regularly
you are what you know right right well
we all measure ourselves up against some
idealized version of what that means or
is
and the truth is you know 99.99
of people that are running are not you
know
winning marathons and things like that
this is the greatest participation sport
but i think what's interesting about
your story and what i'm interested in
is like your example and your story kind
of catalyzed a broader conversation
about body
body positivity and what does it mean to
be an athlete were you surprised
at the kind of narrative that emerged
out of what you've done
or is that did you
see that coming uh i did not see that
coming
and i was surprised by the narrative
because i just did what i needed to do
for my body
that and i made it public when i started
a blog and i only did that because
someone suggested that i do it um and
it still is surprising to me that this
is even a story right i'm a factor
continues to grow like you're everywhere
like i
i first came across your story by by way
of that rei
video that kind of went viral the murder
vader but
i keep seeing new stuff popping up all
the time like people are
continuing to discover your story which
is wild right
and you're like well i'm here for it
okay right
like i i have no complaints but it is it
is crazy to me that it's
that it's a thing um you know as i you
know as i said like
i'm just a person who likes to run and i
like to exercise
but on the other hand i know that there
are lots of people who
for for whom like this thing that i'm
doing is seems to be inaccessible to
them
because they have this idea that a
runner looks this way a runner runs this
quickly
um a person who hikes
is a certain body type a certain race
probably male um
and so when they see me it
blows their minds that i'm out there
doing those same things
um unapologetically
and without regard for what
people think i should be doing and where
people think i should be doing it
the unapologetic part is a big part of
it too like you always have this huge
smile and you're the life of the party
on the trail
and i think i don't know about the life
of the party well there's this sense
like oh well you know i'm here but i
really shouldn't be here like the
sheepishness
that perhaps somebody you know somebody
else who's uh who's
you know trying to make this work would
feel
in that experience well i definitely
when i started
trail running i didn't know what i was
doing
nobody does right i still don't know
what i'm doing
um but you know i would just kind of
like
hang in the back and listen to the race
directors and and then
go off on an adventure because i always
see it as an adventure
and again not knowing what i was doing
not knowing what i was in for
and um and but as i became
used to that and more comfortable with
that
um like the unknown
aspect of of trail running and anything
that you do
in the outdoors i definitely became more
comfortable
just being in those spaces um
and that's just some that's how i
operate in any
uncomfortable situation i'll hang in the
back and
observe learn things uh and then as
i become more comfortable i um
what's the word i'm looking for
acclimation well i
acclimate but i'll i extend myself more
and more
when i'm in those situations what's also
interesting is that
you know trail running isn't exactly the
most diverse sport
out there yeah right so
so juxtaposed against running more
broadly
you know black people dominate running
in
you know all the way from the 100 meters
to the to the marathon but you don't see
a lot of black people on the trail
you don't uh that is true
uh and that's there are a lot of reasons
that um it is that way
in trail running and in hiking because
obviously those two are related
uh i think um and
people definitely are surprised when
they see me on a trail
you know unless they know who i am
already but
uh when you're famous about famous but
you know like it's you know in the niche
in a trail running niche i
you know people people know who i am and
so it's not
as much of a surprise but if i'm
somebody else um
hey hi how are you you where are you
from and there are a lot of questions
and um
that try to get up why you're here
um and you can read it in people's body
language too
um sort of questioning like oh wow how
did this person get
here why why are they on this trail um
and so i definitely have had experiences
uh when for example i was i signed up
for a hiking
a a group hike out of a store in new
jersey and
the hike leader even though i was
dressed in
trail running clothes and i was i mean i
was decked out i had my nathan
and i had my trail running shoes my wool
socks
i mean i was decked out but she only
came to me and asked me if i was
ready for this hike and it could have
been because i'm fat
i don't know but i was also the only
black person there um
did i have enough water and have a
hydration pack
um at do you have food yeah i've got
bars
i'm good i'm i'm good you can go pay
attention to the other people that are
here
so um so that happens sometimes
but um you know there's there there
there's a lot of history behind why
outdoor spaces that are in forests uh
are considered to be white spaces
uh and so so number one that might make
them
um inhospitable for people who
are not like me i i will stick my ass
anywhere
i feel like i belong uh but a lot of
people don't
have that sense of entitlement so um or
don't know that they could be out there
hiking or trail running too because look
at the representation in media
who do you see you see what you see
people like you rich yeah
it's you yeah uh maybe a lady
um and you don't definitely don't see me
although i have been
privileged to appear in a lot of
publications um
but i'm only one person um and i'm
honored to be able to
be that one person uh so that people can
kind of see themselves or envision
themselves doing the things that i do
but there isn't enough um so i think
representation is
um really really crucial and uh lacking
uh in terms of what we see as
the outdoors who we see in the outdoors
and who we see doing
these outdoor activities yeah yeah yeah
it's it's it's wild you know you
mentioned that
there's a lot of history behind why
outdoor spaces
have been considered off limits to
people of color
like what it you know that's it's
sickening and disheartening to hear that
i believe it to be true but i can tell
you that i haven't spent a lot of time
thinking about why that might be
well if you think about how the
national parks were formulated
and how that land was stolen from
native populations um without regard to
any of their history or their domiciles
um
i mean that's just one part of that and
and i
and i also think of how um
just land in the u.s ownership of land
is very very white ownership of any sort
of real estate or land is
is very white and
so when someone like me
appears uh like i look like i don't
belong
because the ownership of land has been
traditionally white
and so i mean there's the government
there are there
are private entities um that are also
responsible for this sort of
whitewashing of land in
uh in the u.s um and and then there's
you know white supremacy
white supremacist ideology um
that that has it that
you know black people don't belong and
we are we are seen as nuisances
in many different types of spaces so and
there's research on that too
on like blacks as a nuisance
in public spaces
it's really heavy you see i'm smiling
because it's so heavy
um and it's and to have to
think about that constantly but and i do
think about it constantly
like every second that i'm on a trail i
mean i may be smiling and i may be
gracious and
um affable but i'm always always
thinking about
whether or not people think i belong and
you know
somebody can ask me a dumb ass question
uh are they gonna say something stupid
or are they going to make me feel as
though i'm not welcome i'm always
thinking
of that and which is why i'm like so
effusive with my cheer
because i have to be do you yeah you
feel like part of that is
a defense mechanism to put other people
at ease
which makes you feel more safe
absolutely yeah yeah i mean that's
that's the story of every black runner
yeah every single person who goes out
and runs
um who is black you know they we have to
signal
you know there's a term for it it's
called signaling
uh to signal to other people that we are
safe to be around and we are not a
threat
so um yeah you hear stories of of
black runners who will wear a sweatshirt
or a t-shirt that has a
fancy college name on it or something
like that to make white people feel like
yeah this person is not a surprise it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what you put on i i
you know again i
i'm always decked out in the latest gear
right
i wear bright colors i you know
i've got my running cap on my trucker
cap on
race shirt or something that signals to
people that i'm a runner
i was when i still lived in georgia i
was running down my
own street um
and i was two miles but i had
done 14 miles and so i was finishing up
the last two miles to
do a 16 miler on my way back home
a woman in a white suv was coming in the
opposite direction
and stops about a quarter of a mile away
from me
i'm slow so it takes me a long time to
do a quarter quarter of a mile so i was
still pretty far away from her
uh so she stops she takes out her phone
she's looking at me she's talking on her
phone
looking at me talking to her phone again
i am like
really decked out i mean sweaty
but really decked out in all my running
gear and uh
and then she gets off the phone and
slowly rolls by me and looks at me
and i wave i'm smiling hey um
wondering what the hell she was doing
yeah okay and then not even five minutes
later
a cop car rolls by from that same
direction that she had been going
and he slow down roll down the window
look at me
i wave in my head i'm like what the [ __ ]
right and that cop rolls away and then
another one comes from the opposite
direction um
slows down rolls your window down
um and then i wave again hey
have a good day and uh in your
neighborhood this is
two miles away from my house and
[Laughter]
you know in my head i'm like i'm just
running i am
running i did have a walking stick that
i carry
because there were lots of dogs there
like no leash laws
where i used to live and so there were
dogs everywhere and so i would have to
bang the
stick on the ground to get the dogs away
from me
um and so but it was a very fancy carved
walking stick and you know and so when i
got back home i
i of course i posted this on facebook
because you know that's what i do
and um and you know we had some laughs
about it and
a friend one friend called me suspicious
black lady running
sblr i'm just gonna get t-shirts made
and um but some other people sort of
question
whether or not you know i looked
dangerous because i had a walking stick
with me
white people of course you know maybe
maybe you know
she was worried maybe she was scared by
the stick you were carrying i was like
in my pink shirt
[Laughter]
my nathan hydration pack and my dirty
running shoes i mean
that's the sort of thing that i think
gives people
pause yeah um there's a sociologist
named uh dr
rashaun ray who has done a study of
why black people don't exercise in
certain types of neighborhoods
because of perceived
danger for their person
and um and it's
and that's exactly it that's what it is
like we
we signal we wave we smile we are
extra friendly and bubbly
but it doesn't seem to matter i mean
look at ahmad arbory just running in the
neighborhood yeah i mean you're telling
the story i can't stop thinking about
him
and and how you know your your story
isn't that dissimilar from his it has a
different outcome
obviously but the circumstances
are related and you can't you can't
you can't listen to the story you just
told without conjuring up what might
have gone terribly wrong
because somebody is confused about
who you are and what you're doing and
that's why i'm there right
right right even though it's very clear
yeah your signaling couldn't be more
clear right and i'm just
picturing you running like what is
threatening about that and what's going
on
with that person in the suv that they're
feeling so
threatened by you where is that
confusion
emanating from and what's going on in
their life that they would
what what what is embedded in their
programming that perceives
that as a threat or something to be
scared of white supremacy is embedded in
their programming that's what exactly
what that is
so let's talk about that i mean you have
you know a big part of your educational
career is teaching diversity right so
now
now you're you're back doing that once
again
including teaching anti-racism right
you're doing this online
yes um so walk me through
what that's all about so i will say that
when i left teaching in 2018 i
had no plans on doing further work in
diversity equity and inclusion because
it's hard stuff
i mean it's really really hard
it takes a lot out of me emotionally and
i was doing it in
north georgia
where it i loved my job i loved
developing curriculum and doing seminars
and workshops
with the students uh it was
tougher to do it with the adults not
even with the parents just with my
colleagues uh not all of them though uh
but it was really tough
it was a boarding school right it was a
boarding school nominally white
predominantly white but you know with a
large
um population of
international students uh and quite a
few people who are
black either black american or from the
islands or from africa
so it was very diverse um for a boarding
school
and uh and so like as i said i had lots
of fun um
doing the work with the students uh and
and
and faculty members who were also sold
on the work of diversity and social
justice
but it was really difficult to do that
work
with a constant opposition um
as far as what i could do what i could
talk about
um you know what was what was
not going to rile up the parent
community and i did
i mean i did anyway i did anyway
i was very privileged in that i could
really do whatever
i wanted to do um had an unlimited
unlimited budget to send people to
conferences
to go to conferences to do programming
but it was still really hard because
you know i was dealing with
a fairly conservative community in north
georgia
and so um there are many things that i
couldn't do
um because it probably wasn't safe to do
um and so they didn't weighed on me very
heavily
and i and i will say that my blood
pressure went up when i was living down
in georgia yeah
and there is definitely a correlation
between racist racist acts racism in
general
and uh hypertension in the black
community
and i you're in a chronic state of alert
right right any any time i'm driving
anytime
i got pulled over twice
um and you know and and i think getting
pulled over for anyone is a stressful
experience but especially for black
people when there's so many
um so many incidences where people don't
uh come out of those
situations alive um it's scary
you know even though i'm a black woman
and doesn't happen as frequently to
black women but look at sandra bland
um he was uh
whose suicide was is very suspicious
yeah
so um you know i'm worried about
my son just kind of existing as a day
student he was
when i was there he was a day student
and so sometimes he would walk back and
forth to school
on a road you know same road where that
woman called the cops on me
and you know he's tall and he's black
and so i constantly worried about him
and
um so yeah i definitely you know
for someone who has never ever had
issues with
uh blood pressure that started when i
actually when i started doing that work
down south and we need
we need diversity education but don't be
too provocative yeah
basically yeah absolutely and that's and
that's why diversity education doesn't
really work
uh you know we can diversity education
is meant to be celebratory like
to to celebrate our differences and to
celebrate the way that that enhances all
of our lives whereas
um equity inclusion and anti-racism
work requires that you are constantly
working like under the umbrella of
social justice work and it's not just
yet we want to
definitely absolutely embrace everyone's
various identities but
there is another part to the work that's
really hard and you have to
be very uh introspective and
metacognitive about your own
attitudes and beliefs and how they and
how they perpetuate racism
right and somebody has to be willing to
probe in
who's on the receiving end of what you
have to say right because
it's easy for me to listen to you tell
these stories
and i think you know as a
white straight male i hear the story of
the woman in the suv and i'm like well
that's not me
so you know i'm not part of that problem
right but the real work is
is looking inward enough to see where i
am playing a part in this right
and and you you have to be open enough
and
vulnerable enough to to tackle that for
yourself and not everybody
is right so i was reading i just pulled
up
this article i don't know if you saw it
um that was in the new york times sunday
magazine
about robin d'angelo's work did you it's
like this long read article about
white fragility is everywhere but does
anti-racism training actually work
right and it sort of unpacks the very
thing that you're talking about which is
you're confronting people with some very
uncomfortable truths
about not just society but perhaps our
own
individual behavior and people get
provoked and defensive and they don't
want to hear it right so
that in turn leads to a bit of a
backlash
and i think we're seeing that culturally
right that is but
this is i love talking about this yeah
so this is why
i want to talk to you okay so uh part of
the
in the course that i teach introduction
to
identity social justice and anti-racism
that's what i do i want to hit people
individually
um and and i want
to bring them to oh i introduced this
framework it's
a framework called
white racial identity for anti-racism
right and by
dr janet helms out of boston college and
there are differing stages right and so
what you just mentioned
kind of people pulling back and shutting
down from those conversations
that is one of the stages of achieving
an anti-racist identity and we have that
first stage which is contact where
people
are colorblind and they don't see color
we're all
you know part of the human race and
and then you uh travel through various
stages
uh disintegration reintegration and each
of those stages
has elements of what you were just
talking about where people they know
racism happens they know
that there is a thing called white
privilege and that
and i'm talking specifically about
people in the white community and they
know um that they benefit from white
privilege but then
but then what right you read white
fragility
you read how to be anti-racist you read
all of these you know
so you want to talk about racism or
um so you can
do that but a lot of people stop there
and they don't continue to examine
themselves or they you know they might
give money to the
naacp defense fund or they might give
money to the minnesota fund
the bailout fund but then they
don't actually do the work themselves or
start venmo'ing their black friends
five dollars okay i have several
did you get any videos i got i got so
much money from people
such a weird thing and i didn't want to
be an [ __ ] and return it
i didn't need the money um but uh i did
get a lot of money hey you know
from people i didn't know right uh or
people who were my followers and i
i really appreciate the gesture i think
uh i think
well it's it's a strange combination of
of good intentions
met with perhaps confusion it's guilt
and shame
that's what it is uh and so that's one
of the stages
uh there was a there's a podcast called
reply all that
that does long-form stories on weird
things that happen on the internet and
they did a whole
hour on this very thing interviewing
black people who'd received money
and sharing their experience of what
that felt like like y'all just hit up my
patreon you know just like
don't don't go ahead i interrupt you no
it's okay but you know
but that you know that sending money and
the whole blackout tuesday
all of that is was
is out of guilt and shame uh that is one
of the one of the stages
of white racial identity um
you know if you're going to eventually
travel
to um doing anti-racism work in your
life right
um but again like if you get stuck there
it's stuck there it's it's um
that's where a lot of the damage occurs
um
if you even get stuck in the next stage
by being stuck you mean okay i did my
thing i did my thing
yes i did my reading i posted the black
square
i'm an ally that's that's who i am i i'm
gonna call myself an ally and i'm
not going to do any further work or any
uh examination of my own
attitudes and beliefs which are probably
racist
um and so you know and then so as you
travel along that spectrum
there is um there's even one
one part of this one stage that is
where you start blaming the victim
um and
you say things like well
he shouldn't have been playing loud
music in his car
he shouldn't have been using a
counterfeit 20.
um or rod shouldn't have been
right he shouldn't have stopped and
looked at this
house under construction he shouldn't
have done that uh
she should have put out her cigarette
when the cop asked her to
but did all these people deserve to die
because they had a counterfeit 20
bill or they were running
um and so so that's actually one of
those stages but you know the thing is
that when you can
be metacognitive and you can observe
yourself having those thoughts
and say oh i'm having this really
negative thought that is probably racist
and damaging when you can do that when
you have the ability to see yourself
saying those things feeling those things
and then you can say well i don't
i don't really believe that i don't um
i know that this is i know that this
sort of attitude perpetuates
racism and then you move on to the next
stage
um where you actually
start doing something you start you do
the reading and stuff and
you start really trying to connect with
people in the white community as i'm and
i'm talking again specifically about
white people
um who are trying also to do the work
um that's that's the only way i think
and you you also have to collaborate
with
people of color so when you say i think
there's a lot of confusion around what
the work is when you're like have you
done the work
are you actually doing the work like
what is that actually the work is
social justice work um all this is
encapsulated under that
that umbrella um where all members of
our society have
equitable access to all the resources
that we have
and and then these resources
and this access are ecologically
sustainable
so that's that's what social justice
work is and and anti-racism is a part of
social justice work because obviously we
there are lots of other isms that we
have to contend with
sexism um transphobia
you know uh ism and you know so there
are
lots of uh other things that to contend
with but you know anti-racism is a facet
of that
and so if you
are saying that you are a person that
does the work
you are continually educating yourself
collaborating with people beyond and not
centering
your own experience
while you are doing the work um and
meaning what do you mean not centering
your experience well
you know um when when people center
their uh own experiences
this is actually it's it's part of um
how lots of conversations get shut down
um against what white fragility is all
about it's all about centering your own
experience
um i don't do that
well well i have a black friend
and or my husband is black or my wife is
black
and so that doesn't happen to me i don't
do that that doesn't happen to me
it doesn't apply to me um it's a way of
shirking responsibility for
dealing with the broader problem or
unpacking what it what isn't
like the systemic imprint of all of this
upon our own
personal psyches that's so deeply
embedded that we're not consciously
aware of how
it gets manifest in our daily lives
and that's that's part of what i do and
um
so in the course you know we talk about
identity we talk about
how identity is the way in which we
experience the world i mean that's our
framework you know our you know our
gender wherever we are on that gender
spectrum our race
all of that informs how we experience
the world
and how people perceive us right you
look at me as a black woman you're gonna
have thoughts
about what it is i probably do how i how
i speak
you probably have thoughts about that
what are you really up to you know what
yeah why are you here yeah
why are you at this hotel you know um
and uh why are you at my gym
[Music]
i could go on and on but you know i mean
but identity it really is that framework
and once you realize
that as a white person or
or as a black person your
world your experience in life is
racialized once you see that
it is mind-blowing and
hopefully you are then able to
see others perspectives and to see
how they might walk through the world or
how they
how they might experience something and
so there's a lot of
um you know when i was it's broadening
your empathy
yes absolutely um you know when i when i
was talking about my
experience running on my own street and
someone
essentially gaslighting me saying like
well you know obviously somebody was
scared because you were holding your
your walking stick and and not
legitimizing
the story that i just told and making it
into something else
um or saying oh that well that didn't
really happen
yeah you know when when we're able to
see others experiences for what they are
there's less gaslighting there's more
legitimizing
of my experience and then hopefully
movement away from blaming me for
whatever
just happened and movement towards
what can i do to help what can i do
with my own attitudes am i what how have
i been socialized
um to believe that you're not supposed
to be running on this road
let me look into that there does
seem to be an awakening right now though
there is a crack in this firmament you
know we're having these conversations
there seems to be
a lot of energy going into trying to
transcend
this you know systemic situation
but at the same time we're now we're at
the end of july
there's been some distance between the
events that catalyzed everything
do you feel like we're perpetuating the
momentum
and we're in a position to re create
real change or do you feel like
it's waning like where how are you
sensing about it right
yeah there was lightning in a bottle for
a minute
we still have that lightning in the
bottle or are we moving on
like we did that many of us are moving
on yeah we did that that's over
um we're a post-racial society again
but i also think there is still momentum
i
i still get lots and lots of calls uh
about a lot of the
you know karen activity you know the the
karen who's in that white suv
is now kind of pivoted to karen's going
crazy about masks
right um you said it i didn't uh but
yeah i mean
so that's continuing to happen and and
really when you
see those videos it's only white people
and white women
uh well just it's white women and white
men doing it you don't see people of
color
doing that uh with the whole fake civil
liberties issue
on wearing masks um but
you know i think to a certain extent
this it is a very ripe time
for doing this work and moving
ahead and as i said like i i am getting
lots of calls
to work with companies and i that's
not what i am used to doing
um you know because i think i have a
different model
uh as far as uh the education the the
pedagogical spin
that i use to um
engage people in thinking about their
identities and how
that is the root of all of this stuff
and
and um different from this different
from
the basic human resources yes kind of
model of dealing with this
and i and i and i will admit that that a
lot of the stuff that i did at school
was that sort of human resources
kind of thing but obviously it doesn't
work
[Music]
uh we need a new model i mean it worked
for what it needed to work for but it
doesn't
really dismantle um systemic and
institutionalized racism and it doesn't
um
so i you know i think
that when i think we have to look at
ourselves individually
you know there it has to be a
multi-pronged approach you have
your if you are in a business or
something like that or your or your
workplace it has to
come from the top it also has to come
from within you have to be ident
um uh examining your
your attitudes your beliefs you know
whoever you are when you know whether
you're white whether you're
a person of color um and using that
knowledge to
to further deepen and improve your
relationships with other people
because you know there's this whole
issue of proximity like when you don't
have a real relationship with somebody
outside of your community
that's where the issues start you don't
know
like that lady on a trail like doing
during the hike she
probably didn't know any black people
and so i was a surprise to her and so
she didn't know how to act
and so she thought i didn't know what i
was doing and so when you don't have
relationships with somebody like me
or um you know out on the trail for
example
you're not going to
treat me in a way that i feel welcome
or treat me like you treat everybody
else and i think that that goes for any
sort of relationship whether
you're in a workplace whether you're
just your personal relationships i think
proximity is
um is is very very important and the
more you know yourself and
the more you know about other people's
identities the better you are able to
relate
so the pedagogical difference that
you're the place that you're coming from
that that's distinct from
the the typical human resources model
is what like what is what are you
finding is most effective
in terms of getting people to think
differently about this and ultimately
behave differently
um first of all with racism uh you have
to be able to name it
so that you can actually see it right
and there are all of these different
types of racism and no one you know
before we didn't want to talk about
racism too deeply
because it's too heavy uh and
a lot of people are coming from this
colorblind ideology where you know we
you know we are all the same people
we're all you know part of the human
race which is true
right but then you when you don't
acknowledge that our experiences are
racialized and that that's where the
problem starts and so um
and so that's sort of the that was the
mo of diversity education right so but
now i think you know when you start
naming racism you start talking about
microaggressions
and what they are what they look like
you start talking about
um you know what
overt racism is you know that's the sort
of kkk
um proud boys boogaloos like that's that
overt racism
uh and yes absolutely it happens but the
other kind covert racism
that's the kind we have to watch out for
um
and so when you can name that when you
can um
you know again talk about
microaggressions or um
or the color blindness because that
perpetuates racism
and actually and people say that they're
colorblind because they don't want to
look like they're racists
well also i think for somebody
of my generation we were brought up to
believe that
this is not only is this the aspiration
but to be
non-racist is to be colorblind right and
that
that belies the underlying truth that
perpetuates racism which
is to acknowledge these differences in
order to transcend them
right and so you're kind of let yourself
off the hook when you say that you are
colorblind and i
i do want to acknowledge that that is a
really ableist term um
color evasiveness is a probably a better
term but it's
not used as widely but um
yeah you uh you let yourself off the
hook you when you don't acknowledge that
this actually exists and that my
experience may be different from yours
because i am black and you are white
um then you are absolutely perpetuating
racism
right because when you when you can't
see it when you don't see it when you
choose not to see it you don't do
anything about it
right right yeah i get that i get that
yeah it's a it's a it's it's a heavy
pill
to swallow but i don't think that we get
to the other side of it without
reckoning with that right in a real way
absolutely and so and
and so what why this is why my approach
is like it focuses on here are all the
different kinds of racism that you might
see
you know when uh when you say that i am
very articulate what are you really
saying
and when you say that with a sense of
surprise and wonder what are you saying
what is your underlying belief that made
you surprised that i'm able to
articulate myself in this particular way
sitting across from me is much smarter
than i expected because my expectation
level is premised upon
a base underlying assumption that you're
going to be
less intelligent right yeah right that's
absolutely what it is and that's
horrible my kid gets no one wants to
think no yeah
of course no one wants to believe that
they would harbor that
even if they're doing it unconsciously
but if you can
see that in yourself uh and i know that
when
i mention that particular thing in my
course and people i
i can see people's body language because
maybe they have said that at one point
to somebody who is black
that is the prime learning opportunity
right there because it's really
uncomfortable now you know and i
and i focus on i was like look this is
uncomfortable work you know i'm not
going to call i'm not going to outright
call you a racist because
i don't know who you are i'm not i'm not
going to say that
but if you can realize uh and
acknowledge that
some of the beliefs that you have that
you have or that you've been socialized
with
are based on racist assumptions and
stereotypes
then we can actually move um so or move
forward rather
um so it's really interesting to to
see that process happening i did i do
get questions
um i actually don't allow questions
while i'm presenting well i saw you
you posted that thread uh you said you
posted that
you like reposted somebody who had
posted a thread
of how you know the questions to ask in
the midst of this kind of training to
disrupt
yeah the the curriculum right right and
you know i'm the boss so you know i get
to
decide how i want my course to be but
because a lot of times it derails the
work
a lot of times people will want to argue
for argument's sake or play this
advocate obfuscation right that's
yeah and so i i'm not doing it this is
my course i developed it
you asked me you came to me and you paid
me to educate you so that's what i'm
gonna do
um and so yeah and so like and it's and
it's great to like kind of lay these
like really heavy things down and allow
people to process it
in pairs um in breakout sessions on doom
uh which is a really cool feature i
think because
you know people need time to
to really uh to relate the conceptual
stuff to their own lives
right here's the definition of racism
here's a definition of microaggressions
where have you seen that in your lives
you know have you seen it happening to
other people has
have uh has a micro aggression occurred
in your own life
you know as a woman has someone said to
you you're strong for a woman
or you're fast for a woman um
you know those are all things that we
hear constantly
uh and they come at us they just come at
us all the time and they have a
cumulative negative effect and so once
people can see that you know whether
we were talking about gender or or class
when you can actually see that and name
it then you can do something about it
it's got to be an uphill battle though
when you're doing this it's one thing to
do it
for people who are going out of their
way to sign up for it and pay for it but
if you're coming into a corporation
and you're in front of a group of people
who
are employees who've just been told like
you have to do this
like that they didn't necessarily
volunteer for it or want to be there
and they're you know leaning oh yeah you
have the body language it's like
resentful that they have to be there in
the first place
in order to really um you know penetrate
that kind of psyche and get them to grok
where you're coming from you're gonna
have to
get them to put their guard down a
little bit but here's yeah there's that
but i
also think that people who think they
are not racist
and who are liberals and progressives
that's the community i want to work with
because i think that's
where a lot of the danger lies when you
think
so elaborately you are not perpetuating
racism
um because that's a lot of people i mean
look at the cooper lady
who uh the in central park um
right the hillary clinton's supporting
the hillary clinton
obama supporting woman
who then turns and
tries to get this black man arrested
we all saw the video we saw the video i
mean that's exactly
the guy who's on the board of the
audubon society the harvard grad
christian cooper yeah um people believe
the name uh the
lady's name is rebecca cooper maybe but
yeah but that's precisely right they
have the same last name
that i would like to work with right
people who
you know they have given money to all of
the progressive liberal
things and they and they think that they
are
they are post-racial and they're
actually not
that's the that's the kind of people i
want to work with the people who are
uh how do you so so that person sitting
in front of you how do you begin to
you know deconstruct their identity
around this
um we go through a variety of of
exercises
uh yeah i have to always define i try to
make sure that i define what these
things are we define identity we define
what you know social justice work is
uh and then we go we go through here
race is an identity
gender is an identity um sexual uh
preference or sexual orientation that's
an identity we go through all of that so
they can see that all of these
things this uh all of these
aspects of who you are you know inform
the way you walk through the world and
so
um i asked them to
look at a part of their identity um
before we start talking about race
and and really examine
where they have been privileged with
this particular
identity uh and how this identity offers
disadvantage
as we talk about privilege and
disadvantage and then it really gets
them thinking about oh well you know i'm
a woman
um and so uh a lot of times people think
i am not strong
or that i am bossy when a man would be
seen as
assertive so in other words you're
trying to get them to
identify with some analog of that
experience
and to be really conversant in the
language i think that is very very
important
to know what those things are because
again when you
name it you can know it
right and you can see it um
and so and there's a lot of pushback oh
well that's so that's just you know all
this political correctness but like
political correctness is really aimed at
people not being [ __ ] and
and thinking before they speak thinking
before they act that's what that is i
mean
and it takes it takes energy and effort
so yeah i mean but i like that approach
because
the alternative is saying you think
you're a good person
and you do all these things that are
civic minded but you're actually not a
good person
well i'm not telling you i know i know
but like but that's how
it will be it will be received right and
then immediately that person's gonna
shut down but here's where pedagogy
comes in
so you give them opportunities to
practice
on the thing that you're not talking
about yet right you give them
opportunities to practice with gender to
practice with
what if you're a white dude like me
right yes but like you know there
there but there are tons of aspects of
identity i mean like you know you we
have
um uh you know in addition to race
ethnicity we've got
uh your regional background that's a
part of your identity
um body image is a part of your identity
because that is very culturally informed
um i say class class um
you know how how does your class
privilege you how does it disadvantage
you
um how does your the way your body looks
how does that
privilege you how does that disadvantage
you
um your leisure activities you know
what does that say about how you are
privileged
in life what does it say about how like
your your lack of access to leisure
activities what does that say
about your class about where you live
about your access to
leisure and so there are all these
different things your family structure
you know a lot of times
um i'm i've been married for 20 years so
a lot of people don't know that
and you know it's it looks like a
traditional family from the outside but
we're not traditional but like your
family structure might
privilege you or disadvantage you a lot
of people thought that i was a single
mom
they probably still think i'm a single
mom because my husband is not on social
media
and so people are going to have a
particular reaction
to me thinking that i am a single mom
you know maybe she's one of those black
ladies that just whatever doesn't
want to get married or whatever um i get
a lot of that
that sort of attitude um or the husband
and the dad
right yeah where's the baby daddy that
that sort of thing
um and so the way you speak your accent
that is a part of your identity the
language you you speak um
the my husband is west african so he
speaks with a
francophone uh french accent
and people will have a particular
reaction you know they'll
slow their speech down and get
louder because they think that
he doesn't understand them and so all of
those things affect the way you
just you are the way you people look at
you the way they react with you the way
they react to you or interact with you
um and so you know you're from maryland
right
mm-hmm maryland michigan originally
michigan
i grew up in europe in maryland right
and so
um but i grew up in i grew up in
bethesda bethesda
right i was born in gross point michigan
like i'm
you know i grew up upper middle class
and then
you know upper class basically like i
come from a privileged background and
i'm a white dude
and i've gone through my life aware
of that privilege but not to the extent
that you're speaking out like i haven't
thought about it
as broadly as i should have right and so
yeah so all of these things uh and well
now's your opportunity
to start thinking about those things and
um and i and i feel like
you know as somebody who's been in
recovery for a long time and who's been
in therapy forever like i'm
i feel you know fairly equipped to do
the introspective part of this and
i know how to take you know personal
inventory of my behavior like
i have plenty of work to do believe me
but i'm probably
better suited to doing that kind of
stuff than a lot of people who
haven't had haven't had the privilege to
have some of those experiences where
they've been compelled to look
inward right in a way that i have i mean
so i don't know what that means but you
know i think it's i think recognizing
that that the work is hard
it's hard and it's important it's hard
for me i mean
like it is so hard uh what about me
in your mind like how does social media
play into all of this there's
great things about it and terrible
things it's being
you know weaponized for villainous
purposes but it's also
cast a spotlight on these issues in a in
a unique way that we haven't seen
in the history of humanity and i just
know that
i can find myself paralyzed wanting to
say the right thing or being part of the
solution
you're smiling and yet feeling like do i
really want to hit
publish on this like what's going to
happen did i get this right am i wrong
where's that fear coming from why do i
feel that way should i
should i not get you know what you know
do you understand this thing like
what's going on how much social media
absolutely plays uh i think both a
positive and negative part
our negative role in all of this
uh and i think that the big social media
companies
facebook instagram twitter
the other ones tick tock uh am i missing
any
there's more myspace friends
throwbacks um i think they have a huge
responsibility
and uh yeah and number one figuring out
like is this the world that we want to
be in
um are we going to be the ones who
who enable racism to continue happening
or sexism or
you know with a whole like gamergate for
example you know that just just
continues to go on and on and on
and you know all in the name of free
speech
but what is free speech really like what
is it
uh is it you know are we going to
continue
to um to denigrate people of
of certain races or sexes or genders or
whatever
are we going to get continue to let that
happen in the name of free speech
you know are we going to continue to
endanger the lives of people
uh who are black who are people of color
who are
women who are trans and i think that
i think social media plays a huge part
in that because uh you know
look at what's happening with
misinformation spreading
and you know on the various platforms
we're you know puppets in this massive
uh experiment in humanity and i don't
think that we're
outfitted to really um
navigate it as consciously as we should
like
they're completely unregulated these
companies are are
you know some better than others trying
to figure out how to get their heads
around
how to better you know create a a
healthier
environment for global conversation um
but
it does not we're not doing a very good
job you know what i mean and
and and and i think it's it's also
making us aware of how easily
manipulated we are
when information campaigns are targeted
in a specific way
to get us to behave and think in a very
specific way
and we haven't really figured out
a solution for this and yet it continues
to grow and expand and become more and
more a part of our lives
yeah and it's really scary it's it's
especially scary and we're both
beneficiaries
absolutely thank you everybody
thank you instagram which makes it make
which
you know creates a another layer of like
weirdness right
it is really weird i'm participating in
this thing i'm benefiting from it
but it's also but you're trying to
participate in a way that
gives back and that gives good stuff to
people
right i i'm trying yeah yeah and i and i
think that
i would say that of myself also i'm you
know i am not
trying to number one spread
misinformation and definitely not trying
to be racist or sexist or homophobic or
or what have you or classist um
but then there are entities that are out
there trying to do that
uh q and on hello um
and uh we're finally trying to crack
down finally
finally look how long did that take
um you know and and and speaking of you
know being in a really weird
space like i just participated on this
facebook panel for community leaders i
have a very large community on facebook
called fat girl running
it's amazing you don't have to be fat to
join
and they really wanted to uplift black
community
or facebook group community leaders um
and it was a phenomenal discussion
sponsored by facebook you utilizing
uh facebook tools that that's the world
that i want to be in
uh but then you have the other side and
you square that with
their ad revenue model and what they're
allowing to take place there
and it doesn't it it's it almost feels
like they're doing that to distract you
from what they're really doing and what
they're doing
what their business is really promised
upon yeah and it's confusing
when you know campaign advertising
is just a drop in the bucket of how they
make their money and it would be so easy
for them to say we're dispensing with
that
and it really wouldn't affect their
bottom line or their p l
yeah so what the question is what what
is really behind that
you know um i mean i don't know it's a
rhetorical question
but maybe it's not a rhetorical question
you know what is
what is behind that uh
the fact that they won't end that
um and by you doing that panel it just
gives you a warm fuzzy feeling
it does and you know i'm like oh
facebook all the way
but yeah and but i don't forget i mean
there is a huge cognitive dissonance
there
where you know you have that part of
facebook that really
sort of dark part of facebook and then
but then all of the
the good stuff and i you know i'm
i'm going to keep doing the good stuff
uh
it's never going to be balanced it's you
know there's always going to be the
dark matter to contend with but um but i
think that's the way the world works you
know we
even though there's a lot of dark stuff
there's a lot of heavy stuff we have to
um i think that you know if you have joy
to exude then you should
if you have good things to give then you
should
um maybe we won't win
[Music]
but you know we should still do it there
is something to be said for
you know the power of the camera that we
all have in our pocket
and the fact that so many of these
incidents that have created the upheaval
were documented on video and shared on
social media platforms that catalyzed
this conversation
there's a cascade effect where that
leads to backlash and a lot of anger
and all the other things that we're
seeing at the same time
but but we can't extract
social media from the
you know the current state of affairs
with respect to the civil rights
movement
right those things are are completely
integrated in a way that i think is new
and
there's certainly benefits to that as
well and that and
it's the way that this generation
operates
you know you think about digital natives
and like that is the way
that they live you think of my son um
you know who does everything is
tick-tock his name is no
talk is is for young people he thinks
17. you have a tick-tock again i do not
have a talk account
my daughter's told me that i was not
allowed to get it i'm also not allowed
to i was not allowed to have snapchat
um i had that for a while and my
daughters were not happy
i haven't used it forever but
um and uh
yeah it's uh it's it's a really
interesting thing uh
an interesting way that they live now um
everything is online and um and that's
how they communicate with one another
well it's creating a whole new language
i mean my daughters communicate
on tick tock not through like they'll
make videos
that are shared publicly that are that
are
in a weird way like communications with
their friends that only they can decode
it's so strange yeah my son makes uh
his big thing is making you uh
gaming commentary videos and
i have not seen any of these stream like
the game
he doesn't stream well he like he he'll
play the game and then
he i don't actually really know what he
does
he has a
with a lot of computers and mics and
stuff and and then i hear him creating
sound bites because that's what they do
and uh
and then commenting on various people
playing games and there's a lot of
cursing
apparently it is you will not allow me
to see any of the videos
because he says that they are
cringe-worthy
but you know that's that's a way of
being for him
and uh whether or not he's communicating
with other people
i don't know yeah
but uh yeah it
it is you know i'm still on facebook and
instagram
um maybe i'll be dancing on tic tac who
knows
right um all right so let's go back to
allyship like what does it look like
to you to be for someone like myself to
be
like a good white ally um i wish we
could get rid of the word ally
let's get rid of it then what would you
just be an advocate be an advocate and
do the work
that's what that's what it looks like it
looks like you
um doing what you do now um asking
questions of yourself
evaluating your behavior your actions
your attitudes
your thoughts all the time it's really
really tiring
but that's what you have to do if you
want to continue doing the work if you
want to be an anti-racist if you want to
call yourself someone who is an advocate
i think ally is a term that's been
diluted um so i think a better
a better way to think of of doing this
work is advocacy advocacy for
other people um and i like i like
transcending the
the the some of these words
that's another word that can't stand
yeah
yeah i read it when i was getting ready
for today i read an article
i was poking around the internet to see
what was new with you that
that i might not have have come across
previously and there was
there was a woman who wrote an article
that that was titled something like body
positivity isn't enough
we need inclusivity and it was premised
upon
her being mistaken for you did you see
this
was it latoya i can't remember i don't
know
yeah we get we get confused all the time
but it was interesting because it was
all about like because you're
you know the moniker that gets attached
to you is but oh she's the
body positivity person but it's really
it's about
moving past that yeah to something
bigger and broader
right you can you can say that i believe
all bodies are good bodies
you can say that but do you really
believe that how are you gonna welcome
that person yeah right are you going to
welcome like
i i am considered a small fat
[Laughter]
there are all these like all of these
names for differently sized
fat people uh there's like super fat and
there's some other
types of fat people but like i you know
to a certain extent
i my kind of fatness is acceptable but
then
anyone who's bigger than i am
and a lot of the body positive community
is not seen as acceptable
so i mean so like the the term body
positivity like what does it even mean
right does it even mean that all bodies
are good bodies or
are only certain bodies good bodies and
so that's why
that's why i i try not to use the term
anymore
um i i do prefer to use
inclusion because you include
more and more people into your sphere
whether it's body positivity whether
it's um you know
whether whether we're talking about
combating and dismantling racism
when you're giving your talks or you're
going to all these races
when there wasn't covid do you bifurcate
the diversity training part of your
brain
and your advocacy from myrna the
mernivator the runner the inclusivity
on the trails person or are these all do
you think of these things
all wrapped up into one sort of thing
because when i get hired to speak
um you know i
all of the various things that i do and
that i'm about
i mean that's what i do you know so if
you invite me to speak and chances are
you're inviting me to speak
to uh to either talk about diversity in
the outdoors
or um or to talk about
you know i give us a thing called um
a workshop called passion forward where
i speak on your work being a reflection
of your core values
and my core values and i present my core
values my core values of joy adventure
community and inclusion that's
everything i am
so and i think that permeates anytime i
anytime i do a workshop that that
sentiment of
you know my core values permeate every
single word that i say
i like that i like the clarity on your
core values it took me a long time
yeah so did you get that did you how did
you what was that process well because
people kept asking me about my brand
what i don't i'm not a company i mean
now yeah
but it's a weird thing isn't it what's
your brand what's your brand
uh and then as i started looking into
what a brand
is uh there was a lot of talk about core
values and guiding principles i was like
oh i can get with that i know what my
core values are
and then and then i had to
i was at an event that i wasn't supposed
to be speaking at
and all of a sudden i was called to
to speak in place of someone who
couldn't make their
uh their workshop and i so i had to
develop a workshop
uh in 24 hours um
on something career related
and so i'm really good at this like
oh you want me to speak in 20 minutes
okay
do you have any idea what you want me
okay i got it i got it done
it's so fun that's from so i came
decades of being an educator
a teacher because sometimes yeah um
yeah i mean it had been a few years
before i would have i would pan could be
because this is a new uh community to me
this is a fancy rei type
outdoor community that i had to do this
in front of and so
i said okay well i'm very happy that i
was a teacher
and i know how to do that i know how to
put together a lesson plan and um
you know have some learning goals and
and some experiential stuff in there and
so that's what i did
and i uh so i said well you know i can
talk about
my transition from being a teacher to
doing what i do
now and how i achieved how i was able to
leave
teaching and still kind of maintain some
integrity about who i am and this new
thing that i do
and so and then i came up with those
those four things
as sort of my guiding principles um like
in
the couple of hours that i had before i
had to do this this presentation
and so as i you know i've refined it a
little bit um
and uh because i had there were some
other things that were my core values
but those
those are the four that really really
speak to me and and
um and are really present in everything
that i do so
yeah and are you still doing the you've
got these running retreats the slow as
[ __ ] running retreats
did you actually do these or did they
did you absolutely did
that's like the best name ever they sold
out you know over and over because it's
like
oh all the fear that people have like i
can't do them running immediately tears
down a wall right
oh well i think i can do that i can i'm
slow as [ __ ] right
exactly exactly and so and that's where
did you what are those about where do
you do that okay so
so yes they are called slow as [ __ ]
trail running adventures
and um i i
i created them specifically to serve
a community that um that is made up of
runners
uh some of them are plus size runners
some of them are not
but but everybody's slow and
uh and by slow i mean we don't run what
are the ten minutes
if you're fast and you want to go i when
i tell people i said this is not for you
this is not the experience for you um
because we're going to be on the trails
we will
run we will walk we will take selfies
we will have a picnic it'll be a whole
day thing this is not competitive you
should not be
uh you should not consider this as
training because
we're just going to we're going to we're
going to play it by ear
yeah play by ear and yes pick daisies
smell them we're going to climb
mountains we're going to do some
we're going to do some sort of uh
reflection work
um and we're having a good time so
uh so yeah like many people the very
first one i did was
22 people which was a lot of people
do you just do it in your backyard
trails
i rent a house somewhere and uh that's
near
a lot of trails and um yeah and i
bring people in i contract a lot of
people into to do yoga
meditation to i you know had uh rasmus
who's a pole dancer come in
and do some sensual movement without a
pole um just so that and
with the goal being that people uh be
begin to
get more comfortable in their own bodies
and in the space that they inhabit
and they transfer that out onto the
trails and hopefully in the rest of
their lives and so
uh so that was fun
and so yeah so that's what we do uh
that's another thing that i'm good at is
bringing people in to create like a
really fantastic experience that just is
not
only centered on me uh because you know
i can
people i can talk about other stuff do
give presentations
stuff like that yeah that are fun that
are engaging so
uh i did my first virtual it wasn't
called slow as [ __ ] it was love your
body
love your body and run uh virtual
retreat and so we did that
and uh had some of the same people do
like raz did her
sensual movement on zoom
uh you know we we read and we um
did some writing uh we talked we did
talk about body image
in that and then both and then the
beginning of the day and the end of the
day were reserved for running
and we and every run was prompted so you
always had a prompt from the the
writing teacher uh that was there that
would
that you'd be able to think about on
your run right so they're like theme
based
i like that that's cool yeah that's the
teacher in me
yeah when do you think we're going to be
able to get back to doing stuff with
people in person again oh maybe the end
of next year
i don't think it's going to be anytime
soon do you have zoom fatigue
i oh absolutely sometimes jesus
i'm on zoom a lot like
uh and everyone wants to
meet now everyone you know what used to
be a phone call
right now it always has to be on video
or facetime i don't know no not at 8
o'clock in the morning anyway
no and sometimes i just i will just
turn my video off and like i didn't this
could have been a phone call i find it
very draining
it is cause you always have to smile
you're always on my
face hurts after every single zoom yeah
uh you know or microsoft teams or
whatever platform they're using but uh
that is definitely tiring but i think
people really are
are hungry for um interaction
and and connection with human beings
outside of their homes
yeah yeah
i know i mean i i don't know i just this
is like my one
outlet where i get to be with people and
other than that i'm just at home
aside from the occasional grocery store
visit
and uh it's definitely you know i
thought
at the beginning of this whole um
coronavirus pandemic stay-at-home thing
like i'm kind of an introvert you know
basically
i like to stay at home anyway i go trail
running by myself
my life isn't that different but it you
know even for somebody like me who i
felt i feel like
i've been training my whole life for
this like i'm gonna be totally fine
it really has created like this
melancholy
that's i think going to be
you know we're i i think we're gonna see
a lot of mental health
issues you know we're already starting
to see it but you know long term and
what is it
what is the impact on young people you
know my i have a 16 year old daughter
and a 13 year old daughter like these
are corona kids like what is
20 years from now what is the imprint of
this
experience on how they think about life
and what their experience is going to be
right i'd worry about my kid who
um he was extremely independent
uh and i mean to a fault
and um you know i remember the first
couple of weeks
that we were in lockdown um
this kid's not afraid of anything but
like in the middle of the night
heard the wind knocking on the window
and
got freaked out and i was like okay
please check in on your kids because you
know it was it was out of character and
they ran into my room was like what's
that you know and so
uh i was like oh whoa this is uh this is
weird because you know
nothing wakes him up ever but clearly he
was having some anxiety about something
and uh about not being able to
we travel a lot as a family and not
being able to travel not you know
not being able to go outside without
fearing getting sick
you know he wouldn't go to the
supermarket for a very long time yeah
what is the
psychological implication of just being
afraid to be
in the presence of another human being
right and it's and it's because they're
in like in this like truly
formative part of their development
as teenagers and so whatever happened
whatever happens now is going to stick
with with everybody but
like particularly you know their brains
are still developing you know that
prefrontal cortex
is not finished growing yet and so
you know i'm sure that there are you
know some genetic imprints
happening now uh because of coronavirus
and lockdown and not
not being able to do the things that
teenagers should be doing it would be an
interesting like sociological
experiment to look at the kids who went
through the 1918
pandemic and to see you know what what
what kind of culture was like 20 30
years later
and how that impacted like choices that
they made yeah because there's got to be
a corollary there
and something we can learn from that
from looking at that yeah
i don't know deep stuff yeah is there a
difference
um living in i mean vermont's a pretty
progressive place
i would suspect compared to georgia yeah
like
it's got to be different for you vermont
is magical it is
i loved where i lived uh i mean like
where i lived in georgia but i
adore vermont um i mean it is
for the most part very progressive and
um
and liberal um i mean i'm very
left-leaning so i mean it's
kind of the perfect place for me to be
um even though it is
i think the third widest state yeah it's
pretty white
in the country um but i definitely
i feel fairly safe i live
everybody knows where i live
uh and where my son lives why does
everyone know where you live because
well i live on a very
uh i live on main street
and i see everything and everyone passes
through main street
um and uh and now that i now that we've
been home mm-hmm you know yeah uh
when i started living there i was still
traveling a lot and so i would come for
like two
or three days what does your son do when
you're going he is uh
my son is into culinary and
um we call him grtb
for gordon ramsay the black wow okay
because he's obsessed with gordon ramsay
and also a culinary so he
right now he's actually right now having
a cooking lesson with with one of my
friends
oh wow um he's learning how to use he
didn't come on this trip
no because he didn't he didn't want to
he was
i said hey we're going to be staying at
a nice hotel and
no just gonna enjoy the fact that i
i'm the only one using the bathroom so
uh yeah again very independent very
um self-sufficient loves cooking
and loves um playing basketball
so he's found a friend um that plays
basketball with him in
in montpelier and you know he's having a
good time he really likes it
and like i i don't worry about him
and actually montpelier has a new police
chief who is black
um we'll see what that means
but uh people are very you know people
are very
interested in social justice and they
work actively towards it
not everybody but a lot of people do um
and there's a lot of
discussion and and conversation
you know after after we had our black
lives matter protests
in montpelier the number of people who
said hi to me as i was running on the
rec path or
you know people you know honking their
horn hey
look you know you can always be nice to
like people i mean that's kind of
that's kind of like the venmo thing
right a little bit
yeah it is it is and even for me it's
like
okay you know i reached out to you for
you to come back on the podcast so
that's
is that really that different you know
because i was like oh i knew you were a
diversity teacher
you know we had a rapport from last time
and i was like
oh you'll be great to come and talk to
you know each other right and we have
had conversations i found myself
thinking is she gonna think that like
because
i said the same thing to uh to
a friend of mine the other day i was
like oh so you know every black person's
phone's ringing off the hook now
right bullets true yeah
and so and and i'm i did that
i reached out to you for you to come
back on and i'm thinking well myrna
think that's weird
you know weird no i think i think that's
part of it i have this skill
so i so i think that um
for me i saw the importance in
exercising this muscle that i have uh um
in terms of diversity equity and
inclusion
at this time um but not for everybody
you know because a lot of people did
reach out um you know hey can you talk
about
this or that you know when when they're
when we don't have any previous
relationship or uh or because they
don't know any other black people
um so i've had to be very judicious
about
uh choosing when and where i speak
and um and with whom right because uh
it is some of your overwhelming did some
of your sponsors reach out to you
for help trying to figure out how to
communicate around this yes
yeah i hope you i hope you charge them
for that uh
because this is like a big it's very
important
they configure their their you know
corporate communication around this
issue that's so
fraught at the moment right like that's
a very valuable
yeah but i but i've definitely said that
as i
i can't solve your company's problems
what you know whatever they
might be in terms of systemic racism or
structural racism within the company but
what i can do
is i can talk to your people and give
them some tools and strategies
for um for educating themselves and for
examining their own attitudes because i
mean that spills over into your work and
your personal life right
so uh you will need to hire somebody
else to deal with that higher
hr level type of thing or the like is
this instagram post okay
right so yeah i don't do that but i what
i do is the the interpersonal stuff
and um and so yes i've definitely
um i have some um
large clients good
you should which i will tell you i mean
you're you're the
you're you you're perfectly suited for
that
you know you have the experience this is
what you do well you know what and it's
and i'm i'm really grateful but it's
it's also like it's very necessary work
uh and you know if i can
give to the movement in this one
specific way then i'm gonna
continue to do it all right well let's
land this plane
but i can't let you go without getting a
gauge on like are we
are you optimistic i'm extremely
optimistic
but my optimism is definitely
rooted in reality so like you know i use
you know what's going on now uh the
awfulness of the situation
or situations that we are
in now and and i use that
to sort of fill myself with hope because
i know
that i know that things can be better
and that i know that things have been
better they can be better again
but we have to do the work in order for
that to happen and so that's why that's
why i do what i do
so someone's listening to this and this
is like their initiation
into thinking about this a little bit
more deeply than they have
where does that person begin if they
can't you know
be privy to your to my very expensive
course
yeah or like like where do you direct
those people
um i
i think you should be reading i i think
reading is really good
um uh you know you
doing all of the uh you know looking
through all the checklists
of 25 resources for
i think that's important i think that's
i think it's a very very uh important
starting point
but i also think that you should and
it's very it's difficult now but you
need to
broaden your circle you need to have
you need to be proximate to different
kinds of people
and start embracing their various
identities
you know examine your own examine the
way in which you were socialized
and then see other people see others
identities
uh embrace them uh
welcome them into your life i think
that's a
that's the way to go for coming here
today
it's my pleasure as always it was fun
you're always welcome here thank you
thanks
um good luck with the surgery in three
weeks ah
at the end of of august yeah um
what's the rehab plan for that how long
before you're back out there
start pt immediately the day after this
is an uh arthroscopic
thing um at stay on the bike
got some bike things coming up yeah
um a potential bike sponsor
oh shameless shout outs
you know where to reach her um oh i
already got one and it works so
okay all right and um
yeah and uh and i as soon as i can but
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
push it i'm not gonna force it i'm gonna
let my body heal
because literally there are no races
until january and that might not even
happen
um so i'm just gonna let myself heal if
i need to keep hiking
and cycling for longer then i'm gonna
keep doing that i mean i still get to be
outside
and i'm in vermont yeah i can stand up
paddleboard even though i hate that
you know i can i can do some climbing if
i wanted to
i could you know i could swim in a lake
so i'm good
cool yeah all right um
if you wanna if you wanna learn more
about myrna check out the show notes on
the episode page i'll link up a bunch of
stuff including a bunch of the resources
that we were talking about earlier
definitely we didn't even talk about
your book we talked about it last time
but a beautiful work in progress
which is a beautiful book you did an
amazing job on that book i highly
suggest
everybody check that out you can listen
to our earlier conversation which i'll
link up in the show notes as well
and you're pretty easy to find on the
internet
basically right yes all right cool
thanks so much enjoy the rest of your
stay here thank you
[Music]
you